[Música]
Hola bienvenidos hoy María Clara calle y
hoy La Crónica de medio ambiente
comienza con buenas noticias porque por
fin tenemos un tratado de alta mar este
va a proteger un territorio que mide dos
terceras partes de todos los océanos y
que actualmente no tienen ningún tipo de
vigilancia Pues están más allá de las
200 millas náuticas contadas a partir de
las líneas costeras de cada país y que
es donde sí vigilan los gobiernos sin
embargo Esto va a cambiar gracias al
primer acuerdo internacional legalmente
vinculante para proteger el altamar y
que fue aprobado por la ONU en su quinta
Ronda de negociaciones así se pronunció
el organismo
Buenas noches
damas y caballeros
el barco llegó a la costa
Y es que después de 15 años de
negociación finalmente los países
pactaron un instrumento bajo la
convención de la ONU sobre el derecho
del mar este Busca conservar la vida
Marina y restringir las prácticas en lo
que se considera como altamar y que es
todo lo que está por fuera de la zona
económica exclusiva es decir más allá de
las 200 millas náuticas desde las costas
las negociaciones tuvieron una sesión
más un duro debate fue en torno al
principio de patrimonio común de la
humanidad Aplica para altamar al
considerar una protección general de un
recurso que es de todos pero los países
industrializados pedían que el texto
mencionara la Libertad en esa zona otros
desacuerdos fueron cómo se reparten los
recursos genéticos marinos qué tan
amplias debían ser las áreas marinas
protegidas y como potenciar la
tecnología Marina si bien falta una
última ronda para terminar los detalles
Es un logro histórico por la protección
que implica en altamar ya que los
océanos se están viendo afectados por el
calentamiento la sobrepesca la
contaminación y entre otros y
ecosistemas como Monte submarinos
respiraderos hidrotermales esponjas y
corales de agua fría son los más
afectados Más allá del tratado Por qué
importan los océanos Es que de todo el
dióxido de carbono que captura la
naturaleza el 90% lo tiene los océanos y
a pesar de ello la humanidad en este
momento representa una de las grandes
amenazas de la vida Marina Esto fue lo
que se discutió en la conferencia award
Ocean que se realizó en Panamá y a la
que asistimos vamos a continuación cómo
está el panorama de estos ecosistemas
marinos
la crisis del océano no está aislada
la ciencia apunta a que nosotros los
humanos Somos responsables de gran parte
del calentamiento global y de la pérdida
de biodiversidad que se sienten incluso
con más fuerza en la vida Marina una de
las maneras en las que afectamos a las
especies acuáticas son la contaminación
el transporte naviero y la pesca el
problema de la pesca no es la pesca
ilegal eso es efectivamente un crimen es
un problema grande pero el problema más
grande en la pesca legal la pesca legal
en la que está llevando a la sobrepesca
de montones de especies cuando la gente
pregunta cuál es la amenaza más grande
al océano La amenaza más grande la
pérdida de biodiversidad y eso ocurre
principalmente o básicamente producto de
la sobrepesca y la sobrepesca es porque
tenemos muy mal manejo pesquero Pero
además porque tenemos falta todavía de
áreas marinas protegidas Porque nos
falta regulación porque tenemos falta de
control pero sobre todas las cosas de la
responsabilidad Max también explica que
a pesar de que la sobrepesca está
contribuyendo a que se extingan decenas
de especies muchos países financian esta
industria
la mayor parte de la de la pesquería
mundial cierto y de la gran pesquería
particularmente de la industria de los
países ricos está altamente
subvencionada Qué quiere decir que la
gente de su bolsillo a través de los
impuestos está pagando ayudando a
destruir el océano Entonces tenemos que
acabar con esa parte porque si seguimos
subvencionando no responde a la demanda
ni a la oferta de algo específico
responde básicamente a que el gobierno
para poder ayudar a ese sector lo sigue
manteniendo eso hay que acabarlo porque
eso es lo que está llevando finalmente a
la destrucción de montón de ecosistemas
y la desaparición de especies además de
la presión que ejercemos los humanos los
océanos están padeciendo el
calentamiento a medida que en la tierra
aumenta la temperatura los polos y
glaciares se derriten esto contribuye a
que aumente el nivel del mar además los
ecosistemas oceánicos son lo que más
capturan dióxido de carbono muchísimo
más que los bosques por ejemplo pero ese
co2 está afectando las aguas pues las
está volviendo más ácidas y hace que el
oxígeno sea menor y esas condiciones son
cada vez menos habitables
el panel intergubernamental de cambio
climático el ipcc ya advirtió que muchas
especies marinas han tenido que emigrar
desde 1950 para poder sobrevivir
el calentamiento del mar y el aumento de
su nivel también provocan por ejemplo
que los ciclones tropicales sean cada
vez más continuos y más severos lo que
está destruyendo más y más a las costas
el aumento del nivel del mar amenaza
vidas y pone en peligro el acceso al
agua los alimentos y la atención médica
la inclusión de agua salada puede
diezmar empleos y economías enteras en
Industrias clave como la agricultura la
pesca y el turismo
una de las comunidades que podrían ser
las primeras afectadas son los indígenas
guna de Panamá se cree que este mismo
año tengan que desplazarse de las Islas
donde viven a la capital panameña para
poder sobrevivir
otra de las grandes amenazas en el
océano es el aumento del nivel del mar
los expertos por ejemplo del panel
intergubernamental de cambio climático
que trabajan para la ONU afirman que el
derretimiento de los polos y también de
los glaciares es una de las grandes
contribuciones a que el mar cada vez
suba más y esto está afectando
directamente a miles de personas de
personas en todo el mundo por ejemplo a
las 1200 personas que habitan en la isla
que hace parte del archipiélago de San
Blas en Panamá en esta Isla los
habitantes hacen parte de la etnia guna
y dos de ellas nos acompañan dos de
estas mujeres indígenas conmigo esta
Laura huertas y Yailín Castillo ambas de
la ong hangar Laura bienvenida y
cuéntenos un poco qué se vive en esta
isla y también en las islas alrededor
Bueno una eminencia desplazamiento es el
primer desplazamiento que se va a dar en
América Latina y es muy triste como país
el tener esa experiencia y de que no
solamente es el problema del cambio
climático sino la parte social en la que
se ve afectada cuando la mujer se va a
sobrecargar también de trabajo y nos va
a cambiar absolutamente la vida porque
no es lo mismo vivir en una isla que
pasarnos a Tierra Firme entonces va a
ser un golpe fuerte para las mujeres
para los niños para toda una comunidad y
no solamente eso sino que se prevé que
en el año 2050 van a desaparecer
absolutamente la mayoría de las islas en
la comarca con Ayala y una de ellas es
la comunidad también de niado que es a
la cual pertenecemos que es donde se ven
las inundaciones también en la misma
comunidad donde realmente existe un
miedo y un temor de poder volver de
nuevo a Tierra Firme porque ya no
estamos acostumbrados y nuestros casas
no son de cemento porque vivimos en una
isla vivimos en junto al medio ambiente
somos parte de ella y eso es un efecto
social cultural
y político también que se mueve yo
Considero que como poblaciones indígenas
estamos siendo muy golpeadas una vez más
por la desigualdad estructural que
vivimos en un país como Panamá y dos por
el cambio climático y ahora más
agregándole ser mujer indígena por la
discriminación también que se vive en
Panamá Entonces el cambio climático
absorbe absolutamente todo
y también está conmigo como ya les decía
yaili Castillo jaily cuéntenos un poco
Cuál es el papel de las comunidades
indígenas y sobre todo de las mujeres
como Laura Nos estaba explicando en el
medio ambiente sí es importante y
esencial conocer que la lucha de un
pueblo indígena no es de ayer ni de hace
dos años sino Son de hace mil años
debido a que la cosmovisión y la visión
indígena con el relacionamiento que
tiene hacia los océanos es son las
enseñanzas que nuestros abuelos y
abuelas nos dan porque dentro de lo que
es el pueblo cuna vemos al mar no como
algo inerte o sin vida sino es ese tema
espiritual que es nuestra abuela mayor
el cual nos protege y nos alberca un
montón de recursos de biodiversidad
hacia nosotros o a la comunidad en la
cual estamos nosotros viviendo el rol de
la mujer representa un rol principal ya
que la naturaleza ese reflejo de las
actividades diarias que hace la mujer
cuna en sus comunidades y somos las que
estamos en la primera línea de acción
ante un desastre ambiental o ecológico
que puede repercutar tanto en estos
sistemas de alimentaria propiamente una
comunidad indígena y este aspecto
socioeconómico y cultural que cada uno
de nosotros tenemos que luchar es por
esto que como mujeres indígenas y Laura
y yo estamos en Estos espacios dando a
conocer y al ser nuestras voces que se
necesita no solamente a nivel regional a
nivel local sino a nivel internacional
más esto más Estos tipos de espacios en
donde la mujer indígena y joven puede
alzar la voz de las realidades que
nosotras mismas conocemos nosotros no
tenemos opciones de que si estamos aquí
por ser activistas climáticas o porque
tenemos o sea es nuestra casa en un
mañana no sabemos dónde vivir somos
Héroes todos los días porque luchando
contra este tipo de efecto que está
causando un deterioro en diversos temas
ecológicos en nuestra en nuestras
comunidades y es por eso que pues
estamos las gracias También a por este
tipo de entrevistas en la cual damos un
llamado a la acción un llamado a la
atención a que también se dé más este
tipo de espacios para las mujeres
indígenas y más que todo en cuna Ayala
gracias a ustedes y mientras para una
parte de la humanidad como usted lo
decía el océano es la casa y la madre de
la naturaleza para otros es una fuente
de negocio uno de los mecanismos es la
minería en el fondo del mar en el lecho
Marino hay nódulos polimetálicos que son
ricos en minerales como níquel cobalto
manganeso y cobre todos estos son
esenciales para la tecnología y la
transición energética pues se requieren
para crear por ejemplo baterías
recargables pantallas táctiles y hasta
paneles solares esta minería extra los
nódulos del mar los tritura y los
desechos los vuelve a lanzar al fondo
del océano El problema es que la ciencia
aún no sabe con exactitud qué tanto
destruye esto la vida Marina a pesar de
la incertidumbre la autoridad
internacional de los fondos marinos ya
otorgó 19 contratos de exploración si
bien el mayor contratista es china
también hay otros como Rusia e incluso
Alemania y Francia a pesar de que este
último se sumó a las naciones que piden
prohibir esta minería también hay
contratos de Islas que podrían
desaparecer ante el aumento del nivel
del mar como Kiribati Tonga y las Islas
Cook la mayoría de las exploraciones son
en la zona clerian clipperton una región
de 5,000 km en el océano Pacífico
central y donde están los nódulos de
mayor interés minero que todavía no
comienzan a ser explotados así la
minería en el fondo del mar trae un
futuro incierto para la salud del océano
y también una enorme paradoja sobre cómo
se podrían afectar estos ecosistemas
marinos a cambio de hacer una transición
energética en la tierra una cuestión que
la ciencia todavía no resuelve y así
terminamos nuestra Crónica del medio
ambiente Recuerden que pueden ver este y
todos los episodios en France 24.com